hey what's up everyone it's Warren and
we have a new Avengers in-game plot
synopsis and this comes from the
Australian Disney website now what's
really interesting about this plot
synopsis is that it lines up with a
leaked plot point that came from a
marketing team that was working with
Marvel and Disney doing surveys so this
gives even more evidence for that plot
leak that we got not too long ago being
real so I'll go over this plot synopsis
I'll break it down and I'll tie it back
in with the leak that we got not too
long ago as well just a reminder that I
started a new giveaway I'm giving away
five imax tickets so you and some
friends can go see Avengers endgame in
IMAX if you would like to enter for your
chance to win all you have to do is
subscribe to my channel like this video
and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite character
that could be a superhero or a villain
so the plot synopsis for Avengers in
game that came directly from the
Australian Disney website reads after
the devastating events of Avengers
infinity war the universe is in ruins
due to the efforts of the mad Titan
Thanos with the help of remaining allies
The Avengers must assemble once more in
order to induce a Knossos actions and
restore order to the universe once and
for all no matter what consequences may
be in store so that's the plot synopsis
from the Australian Disney website it's
not too different from other ones that
we've gotten in the past but the biggest
thing about this one is in the last line
where it says the Avengers must assemble
once more in order to undo Santos's
actions and restore order to the
universe once and for all no matter what
consequences may be in store so the
avengers are obviously going to try and
undo fan OSes actions obviously that's
pretty much the main point of avengers
endgame but then it speaks about
consequences they're going to do this no
matter what consequences may be in store
for them
the Russo brothers have said multiple
times now in many interviews that there
will be real stakes and real
consequences in Avengers in game and
they have implied many many times that
there will indeed be permanent deaths in
the movie and that's what this plot
synopsis implies when they're speaking
about consequences my thoughts
immediately go to the soulstone if the
Avengers are going to try and gather all
of the Infinity stones to undo they
snap then there will most likely have to
be a sacrifice in order to obtain the
soul stone and with a few main actors
contracts up we can pretty much narrow
it down to who we think it's going to be
and like I said in the beginning this
plot synopsis is very similar to a plot
leak that we got a couple of weeks ago
the wording for each of them is very
similar and they both say that the
Avengers are going to have to undo fan
OHS to snap no matter what consequences
may be in store but the plot leaked that
came out a couple of weeks ago also says
that Iron Man will forge his own
Infinity Gauntlet this makes sense
because none of the Avengers are strong
enough to wield the Infinity stones on
their own they'll need an Infinity
Gauntlet but the one that Thanos has is
damaged we saw that at the end of
infinity war and the Russo brothers came
out and said that the Infinity Gauntlet
is permanently damaged so they'll have
to forge a new one if they want to
control all of the Infinity stones so
lining this plot synopsis up with some
other plot leaks that we've gotten in
the past it looks like there are going
to be some serious consequences in
Avengers in game which may include some
deaths and it also looks like the
Avengers are going to have to forge
their own Infinity Gauntlet and collect
Infinity stones for themselves which if
all of this ends up being true it sounds
like it's going to be insanely awesome
the plot synopsis is already taken down
off the Australian Disney website which
implies that it really wasn't supposed
to be up there in the first place which
also implies that it is in fact real so
let me know your thoughts on this let me
know if you think Tony is going to wield
an Infinity Gauntlet or if you think any
of the other Avengers will wield the
Infinity Gauntlet let me know in the
comments down below and again don't
forget to subscribe comment and like the
video so you can enter the giveaway and
stay up to date on everything related to
Avengers in game as always thank you all
so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]
you